i think in little doses it's fine yeah
you know it feels you know
there was a reaction
korea town last night
what are we creating what was the story
i mean he went full-blown korean elvis
outside of sununu our favorite
restaurant what are you talking about so
first a guy asks for his photo and then
a second person
and then usually at that point you're
like okay i'm gonna chill in this corner
while i'm waiting to get seated in the
restaurant and just retreat right yeah
no instead he does he doubles down he
starts showcasing
he starts doing a dance in the corner
and then more people are like whoa
that's bobby lee and now it's like
and then he starts to
on peacock i didn't do it then he starts
like poking at people like yeah
and then now it's like 60 people who
want to take a picture with him and he
is just in heaven i don't know
every every now and then that's cool
though i think that's great you know
what like
that's why you have to you have to deal
with that so much right that that you
have to hide a lot of times and then
sometimes it's just cool to
i never hide you never oh okay
in fact he will take a couple laps
around a pomona mall oh i see just to uh
but i'll tell you why and and and
i'm going to tell you why
i'm going to tell you guys why because
now i'm on the defense
i'm protecting myself
but um
you know
you know uh i just want to say that you
are you have a lot of talent
but you're also you know a cute kid
let's be honest right
um i was when i growing up i was never
considered a cute kid
and i was um
really shy i wanted to be noticed and no
one would notice me
and um and and um you know that's why
sometimes when people
notice me
i showcase
they dance and
act silly
and i run around like a little baby and
um that's fine you were in that thank
you i think that's sick you know what
thank you
you're saying that and i really
appreciate it
so then um
who you who are you friends with on that
season of the voice um
i was friends with a lot of people my my
whole entire mindset going into it was
kind of like
jam out with as many people as i can
there were people that played piano some
of them played guitar some of them were
country you know you had you have
everybody you you know um but it was
just like wow i get to hang out with all
these different types of musicians how
many can we fit into the hotel room and
just like jam out